anyone who needs to put
this much of a spoon in their mouth
deserves 12 sins no
16. this is cruel we better let him
finish before his head explodes
you promised you wouldn't do that
anymore sheldon doesn't seem like the
sort of person who would wait for
permission to speak his mind and no he
isn't waiting for an appropriate
breaking conversation before spewing out
his tapioca pudding knowledge he had six
full seconds of silence before leonard
asked him to uncork his mouth
also why is he yelling at leonard when
howard was the one to persistently
interrupt sheldon's inane desire to
verbally vomit wikipedia articles
well i think we're off to a terrific
start unfounded optimism is
unfounded dressing every character
except the female in seven layers of
clothing
i mean the email doesn't bother me as
much as the vacation pictures of him in
a bathing suit
oh poor penny forced to read every email
and look at every attachment i swear the
porn was just a pop-up i didn't mean to
click
we're on to you penny that's not a
bathing suit it's a tan line
hearty heart penny didn't know it was
his penis but seriously how would she
not know it was his penis did she think
it was a bathing suit with a penis
painted on it
how did you guys become friends hey hey
hey we already sinned that episode but
for making me think about enduring
origin stories
twice here are two sins and you moved in
anyway
i assumed he was joking sure you could
assume that the roommate wanted
whistler's need not apply was a joke but
after meeting sheldon you had
plenty of time to run wait how many
questions are on this thing
only 211. i see maybe five sheets of
paper here and with this size font there
can't be more than 32 questions tops
it's kind of cute until you get to the
scrotum scrotum shaming
if this is sheldon's desk and this is
leonard's who sits back here do they
have an invisible third roommate did
that person receive a questionnaire
the data is skewed if they're not
included you're driving me to the mall
i'm going to acquire a book the mall
books books at the mall do you have any
books about making friends
um yeah but they're all for little kids
this is either a terrible bookstore he's
just a lazy employee because there are a
ton of bestsellers written for adults on
this subject one of the biggest is how
to win friends and influence people it
literally says how to win friends in the
title
looking for a murder mystery this
section here oh wait no this is the math
section no psychology wait psychology is
over here with prophecy in a duplicated
biography section which is also above
another biography category that happens
to be nestled between anatomy and
dieting the sort of dewey decimal system
is this maybe sometime you and i could
go see
monkeys together this girl doesn't
immediately find an adult
and i blame her parents for forgetting
to teach her this very important rule
if a stranger wants to show you a monkey
punch him in the funky junkie
i'm making friends with this little girl
yeah perhaps
the two of us might share a meal
together if kripke agreed to share a
meal with sheldon the follow-up is to
repeat the question to dine together
even more confusing is the next step
which appears to be to
begin friendship rather than decide when
and where to meet to eat who's going to
pay or if there any food allergies to
consider
yes i'll pay oddly sheldon's current
flow chart progress does not lead to
begin friendship torturing your tinkle
also what is the purpose of this
punching bag do people regularly want to
hit something before or after climbing
rocks
is this a thing also also why is this
[ __ ] not immediately lowering sheldon
to the ground
why aren't you doing your job what is
this terrible place
i brought my new friend barry kripke
home for dinner
oh if you walked into a house and nearly
everyone inside the house audibly
groaned at your arrival would you stay
and yes they clearly set barry up to be
an [ __ ] but even [ __ ] have hearts
trust me you two are safe oh
come on what do i have to do stop going
to sheldon's house
stop answering the phone or just whistle
apparently
oh whoa wow yeah it's not a very hot
name i'm gonna call you
roxanne everyone around this table is
willing to endure sheldon booting out
their friend raj for answering a
question incorrectly
and watch this asshat disrespectfully
speak to penny without objection
none of these friendships are healthy
everyone here is toxic suddenly i'm
looking pretty good huh
nope you're still the one who sent the
pick
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
do
partial facial paralysis temporary
blindness
drooling bleeding gums did you know that
we create monthly exclusive videos for
our sin club members bonus outtakes
i don't know peter meth is a hell of a
drug extra sins videos
strange things are a foot at the circle
k
and even member chosen sin commentaries
i love this
i love this this kind of of a sin
because it's just
it's so silly pick our next video and
see the exclusives at patreon.com
cinemasins or click the link in the
description below spiderman is not a
parade you do not need to stop traffic
for spiders
first warning do you want to play
questions
you have to ask questions statement
sheldon i'm not going to defend a big
bald raccoon i just wanted that
that book has been on a wild ride
what's your name marty as in martha this
is awkward i feel like i'm
my first junior high mixer randy lay
there like a slug
it was his only defense